hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger c'est lui qui gagne
c'est qu'il gagne avec enora celui qui
perd il est allé laissant aller ses
portes il ya eu du mieux
alors c'est parti à me renvoie le [ __ ]
je peux jouer comme ça pendant deux
heures pour tous les prêts moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
megan et patrick si vous voulez je fais
c'est un petit point dom la lévée les
petits points râler d'accord un petit
poêle jusqu'à 1,3 à leurs dires les
allées d'un départ oui c'est la couleur
directe à l'image il commença toilettes
communes
je n'ai pas qui paierait des fois ça se
joue sur ce court ressources lointain
est parti c'est la balle de match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
pratique patrick et tendre email à
répétition tout à l'heure ouais c'est ça